c'est au nom non madame mademoiselle
monsieur bon sang de bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir
voici quelques nouvelles en bref tout
d'abord des faits divers des
contestataires ont envahi hier soir le
studio de roger gicquel pendant le
journal de 20 heures le célèbre
journaliste de tf1 s'est immédiatement
réveillé
huit ans après que la place de l'étoile
est été débaptisée est rebaptisée place
charles de gaulle 9 français sur 10
c'est un sondage qui nous confirme
continue de l'appeler place de l'étoile
en signe de protestation contre ce
laisser-aller les gaullistes historiques
manifesteront demain à 19 heures rendez
vous place de l'étoile
en sport dans le concours par équipes
des plus gros derrière de france c'est
l'équipe des 40 fès qui a vaincu sur
notre carnet mondain joli cas la garenne
raison madame jeannette le lapin a donné
le jour à cette quintuple et je dis bien
cette quintuple et c'est étonnant et
c'est d'autant plus étonnant que lors
d'une première grossesse
madame le lapin avait eu un seul jumeaux
pour lire sur les plages car il faut
aussi lire sur les plages les presses
marine de france viennent de publier un
ouvrage sur la vie sexuelle des huîtres
au mois d'août
certes c'est un ouvrage qui n'est pas
tellement qui même carrément l ouvrage
austère enfin les huit ne sont pas un
sujet de plaisanterie fines de claire
numéro 3
[Applaudissements]
oui comment saatchi au caractère inné la
fin comment hachey
c'est encore monsieur tino rossi qui
nous annonce que l' incendie de ces
gravats maintenant pratiquement éteint
grâce à l'intervention de trois canadair
c'est quand même étonnant de toute façon
je m'en fous s'est passé pour mon pognon
et je vous remercie de votre affaire si
de votre attention
merci d'autres attentions fait membres
[Musique]